fozia Manita was paralyzed below the
waist when she was only two years old
like many disabled people in Libya a
lack of infrastructure means it's
difficult for her to move around
growing up I couldn't go to school
because there were no ramps it's all
stays my father was scared I would fall
and hurt myself even now most schools
don't have ramps so many disabled
children can't go to school
she's always dreamed of getting an
education now she visits this High
School where teachers offer her tutoring
but it's not easy the challenge
Organization for Women with disabilities
aims to create a safe and friendly
environment for its members
it's a small but welcoming place for
more than 57 women who are disabled
here they meet and make handmade items
to sell like dolls pillows and blankets
sales help fund field trips and
activities
created the organization
women with disabilities in Libya suffer
from so many problems starting from
their homes many families do not build
ramps and only have stairs the bathrooms
are not accessible by wheelchairs so she
has to crawl this causes a lot of
frustration and psychological distress
we've met some girls who tried to commit
suicide
this parking lot in the heart of misrata
is close to Banks the city council a
courthouse and other public buildings
volunteers and organizations have marked
out a few parking spots for disabled
people
but without government backing there's
no control over who parks there and no
ramps to help the disabled get to them
Ramadan matig heads the Civil Society
Commission in misrata he says things are
slowly getting better
regime disabled people were completely
marginalized but after the revolution
many were wounded in the fighting and
thus created a shift in our society
looks at disabled people in general the
government is now researching on how to
renovate old buildings to make them
accessible for the disabled
although there aren't accurate numbers
the government estimates there are at
least 120
000 disabled people in Libya the actual
figure is probably far higher because of
war and conflict
in Libya women are widely believed to
suffer the most from the lack of
infrastructure but staff in
organizations like this say they help
ease the pain Malik trainer Al Jazeera
misrata